[Music]  breaking here at four o'clock new  details surrounding an officer-involved  shooting nearly a week ago it started as  officers investigated an armed robbery  suspect for alleged crimes committed  back in may that turned into a dramatic  car chase where police say the suspect  justin benegas stole an suv and fired on  them multiple times metro police say  during the pursuit venegas made multiple  stops trying to carjack other victims  but was unsuccessful  displayed reckless behavior as he drove  around congested areas of traffic  and at times his speeds would reach in  excess of 100 miles per hour  well the chase came to an end when  officers say venegas rammed into a  parked k-9 officer's vehicles damaging  both vehicles now that officer received  minor injuries his k-9 partner was not  hurt venegas faces multiple charges  including attempted murder